and yeah so very many thanks to the
organizers for inviting me I very much
enjoy being here this is work with
andrew and pablo and i'm currently in
singapore but next week i will be a
ended and it's qtek which is some kind
of new quantum initiative which exists
since this summer and i think it's going
to be very exciting all right be sure I
have some good news and some bad news
should we start with the good news or
the bad news the bad news our way that
was okay so like even though I'm
obviously one of these quantum people
you can already see it here there will
be no beautiful physics pictures in my
talk the possibly good news at least for
some of you is that I have tried to
eliminate any and all quantum notation
from this talk and I will make an
attempt to kind of I guess communicating
in a language that is more familiar to
you if I do sometimes use some wrong
terminology please bear with me I'm I'm
trying to serve slowly liking what you
see maybe babe
okay so I guess you know all about and
what we want to do so we want to
maximize or minimize some polynomial
over some space V so what is this need
so let me give you some examples that in
particular will be interesting in this
talk so for example we might be the
hypersphere of dimension n it could also
be a complex projective space it might
also be discrete objects like the
bouillon cube but what I'm going to say
is also going to apply to general and
romanians metric spaces and nice
discrete objects so for example if this
was like over a ternary alphabet and you
could play the same tricks even though
we will see in the end that you need to
know a few things about the space be in
particular some properties of orthogonal
polynomials relevant to me but I'll get
back to this so what is going to happen
in this talk so if you only remember one
thing then this is you can read our
paper in the nearby future so we have
some general procedure to obtain
convergence bonds for semi definite
programming hierarchies and these
converted sounds are based on so-called
kernel functions I will explain to you
what that means so for every kernel
there will be some kind of convergence
guarantee and it encompasses some of the
existing hierarchies in particular I
guess for the quantum people here also
the way of writing it on some kind of
tensor products of system we will obtain
explicit representing measures and in
particular we also get some improved
convergence pounds for optimization over
the hypersphere so this is some example
that I'm going to discuss in particular
so like I said our results apply to all
kinds of objects however for simplicity
for this talk just always think about
the sphere and so what I want to do is I
want to optimize the polynomial in some
variable X so X is like n elements and I
want to live on the sphere so basically
have a spherical constrain and I wanted
to find the maximum of me so I mean is
yoga know what polynomials looked like
this is something
so kind of how difficult is this problem
and if the polynomial has degree at most
2 then this problem is actually easy so
I guess this is a problem for example
for this polynomial on the sphere it's
easy but for degree larger than to
infect the problem is np-hard so I guess
you're familiar with these kind of
results so this polynomial for example I
guess this is quite simple and so the
question that I'm going to be concerned
with is kind of okay so finding the
exact solution is kind of difficult so
how difficult is it to approximate the
max so I'm going to list some results
and these are non exhaustive and Aaron
already gave you awesomes earlier and so
if you want to know there's actually a
survey which I guess by now is a little
bit later that discusses optimization
over some objects like this simplex the
sphere and the queue and there's also
some approximation algorithms for very
special class of polynomials which about
focus polynomials there's also some
special cases considered in computer
science and I guess Aaron talked about
them earlier today and which are
basically sums of products of
polynomials of low degree
so there's also some results by if I
bousillage going back to earlier results
for Resnick which gave some
approximation guarantees for stp
hierarchies if I'm Brooke optimizing the
polynomial over the sphere so there are
some earlier results by Andrew and
myself and that's obtained using some
kind of quantum inspired techniques very
similar approximation guarantees that
had previously been obtained by by 45
bousillage and using however quite a
different method in particular you can
understand what's going to happen in
this talk is actually a much more
general version of what we're doing here
you might argue that if you were to
truly understand the proof here why it
actually works then what I'm going to
discuss it's going to be very natural
and also give something better than
sounds are we're exposing you to my
handwriting so I guess you are familiar
with this but let me maybe briefly
summarize so typically when you want to
optimize the polynomial over this fear
you could also ask let me optimize the
following so optimizing overall measures
here so you should be thinking about
this here as some kind of
old is a probability measure because I
really want to emphasize so this is
normalized so first now we haven't
really gained anything it's just as
difficult as solving our original goal
but I guess you all familiar with this
writing it this way it now suggests a
very natural way to relax the problem
giving a hierarchy of semi definite
programs that will get us closer and
closer to just true optimal
so let's say that I want to optimize
over measures so here I've just written
what we had before so I wanted to
maximize so here's my LM I will call it
m to indicate that really here and
optimizing over a true probability
measure ability measure satisfies a few
properties so for example it is
normalized meaning that I integrates the
whole thing so in this location valuated
at the constant function so i guess from
optimization you were very familiar with
this kind of really i think this is some
kind of pseudo expectation for the
quantum people here you might think that
I'm taking the trace of the density of
so this is equal to 1 and of course the
next thing that I want is I want that
these things here are positive so the
idea about forming these relaxations is
to now keep one so we're going to keep
this positive in constant so we're going
to demand the constant function i
evaluate to 1 but here I'm going to
relax the positivity constraint in a
llamar i am only positive for event
evaluated X squares of polynomials that
have a certain degree any so of course
it depends a bit what L is so the larger
and larger I make L the kind of closer
and closer I get to this positivity
constraint because positivity is true
then this is true for all degree
polynomials arbitrary Dante and so you
can think of this earlier as kind of
telling us which level of the hierarchy
where at
so the relaxation looks like this let me
just write it again so he'll be
maximizing or minimizing over this here
so I minimizing some polynomial size
shape normalized and I positive up to 11
else of the same and if I'm on the
sphere I also wanted to have the
constraint that's when I am indeed he
okay if you actually write down the SP
in terms of macy's this with maybe walk
with you to me or maybe it's obvious to
you from from this location opening
that's like this one I don't need to
write down explicitly anymore and in
fact what's going to be relevant is
going to be constraints on
so our freedom so not where did we relax
the problem okay so if I minimizing and
maximizing so note that here I've kind
of enlarged the set of matrices there's
a minimizing over so actually this is
from somebody will talk and where I was
actually maximizing so i got this the
SDP solution was larger than the
original one here because I now change
this to your notation and I'm minimize
of course this minimization gives us a
smaller value than the original problem
and because I lo more
so I'm going to do now is I'm going to
talk about what L colonel and I know
kernel-based rounding then I will talk
about the approximation guarantee and
then we will write on this and in the
end I will talk about how to choose the
right kernel or when a current that
gives us a good approximation guarantee
so let me first say a bit about what is
a kernel and what properties of this
colonel am I going to assume
so again maybe for the quantum people
given that i've converted everything you
might say how about my favorite stp hi
Ricky I want to write it down on the
tensor product or spaces so you might be
this special case of what I'm going to
do that's
so what is the colonel so a colonel is a
function from like our space knee so for
example is here and this here to the set
of real numbers that can be diagonalized
so i guess you can say mrs. like in
terms of a disease in the sense that i
can and some ID functions so you can
think about these as being functions is
also long division object that we
interested in for example this view so
let me give you an example of this a
kernel function so for example one
possible kernel which is called the
polynomial kernel if i take the
Euclidean inner product of two vectors x
and y on the sphere and I race it to
some power
so it turns out that what Andrew and I
was doing we're doing earlier in fact
this is the kernel that we were
implicitly using but we're using some
more general set of curtains
so let me tell you a little bit more
about curls so I guess what's the feel
of a million it is but maybe some people
not so much so just like em with
matrices and kernels can have degenerate
eigen value so this just means that like
it's possible that this month that J
occurs here multiple times anything else
much I can kind of punch these
eigenfunctions here together into space
is kind of depending on the same eigen
thing so let me define RM so here all of
these together that have eigenvalues
equal to lambda
and of course I can just rewrite my
Kernaghan in terms of mouth and say for
if the ones that brush guard times this
erratic
so I'm calling it rmx why because it is
itself the colonel and in fact it has a
property that is called reproducing so
what else is new so this current here is
reproducing for all functions F which I
look about them which are in the span of
these functions EJ here namely such that
the eigen value lambda J this is mean to
be in a span so it just means that i can
write f s some combination of these
functions EG if the space a name I'll
get back translated so let me call this
here HJ so this is basically the space
of all these function how does it now
mean to be reproducing so this R is
reproducing for this space or functions
HJ if for any element I have the if I
take the integral over the sphere with
respect to the information of em is this
function and this reproducing kernel
well I get back the original function
now evaluated at the point X so you can
think that what i'm doing here is that
basically this here is currently this
kind of if i kind of take this integral
is constant on this particular space
so let me say a bit more about this of
course you already know one particular
colonel namely they fully reproducing
kernel fully reproducing means that this
whole it's not just for some functions
in some sub space of all possible
functions but indeed for any function
that I might want to write down so if i
integrate like f with respect to fully
reproducing are so you know such a
function like the data function no i'm
not quite sure if i'm using the right
notation for you and but some people
like to write it like Delta X Y and
which is the same as the fully
reproducing innocent
yeah and I wanted to point out one thing
so I had said what are I gain values of
the colonel just one slide ago so if we
think about what are the eigenvalues of
this fully reproducing kernel so these
here are all one so this completely flat
their own one and this makes the kearney
before you were produced
nothing useful to keep thank you you can
think of the sum over RM at the Delta
function
so in this talk I will be interested in
Colonels which I will call ballot
currents so I will call a colonel valid
if it has the following form so first it
satisfies this property namely it is in
fact the square of another function
theta of X
this here is a polynomial in wine of
degree at most n so L will be the level
of our language so this property number
one it's not quite clear on this place I
love it and the second one is that
infects the polynomial that are
interested in can in fact be expressed
in the following way so i can write this
is sum over j of functions TJ TJ is an
element of the stage stream so notice
that my kernel defines these spaces I'm
going to diagonalize it I write down is
eigen values then will be these spaces
defined by this reproducing trans RJ
corresponding to the same eigenvalue
ready to kind of give you an example of
what you should be thinking about here
so actually for the remainder of the
talk it's useful if you think about the
space HJ s the space of all monomials of
degree j if you think about a spherical
harmonics for example on the sphere
think about this as being the space
spanned by all spherical harmonics of
degree exactly Jane sorry I don't
understand the connection between the
second condition
so I just wanted that and the thing is I
could basically this definition tool
just says that my Colonel if I
diagonalize it gives me means to write
my polynomial in terms of the
eigenfunctions of the colonel this is
all the condition really says oh I see
there's our remember boys and the
minutes on Zeta can be arbitrary so I
mean later when I optimize other kernels
I'll make this more specific but in the
moment to think about this condition so
conditioned to is just to ensure that i
can write the polynomial of interest in
terms of functions and english return is
also they are i will assume some
notation yet so h0 i will call the space
of constant functions and HJ will be the
space that is defined by these RJ's come
from
so let's consider some current like this
and let's see what we can no actually do
so remember that we actually wanted to
solve an sdp okay so let me call a new
stp the kind of optimum that I get when
I actually go and solve
it's not difficult to see and in fact
especially in this kind of abstract
today that they exist some side measure
socializing right they say not sure this
is how you usually write it down but I
find it useful to think about it like
this we have something which I guess in
altum informational quantum optics one
likes to call it king recitation
continues or anything the method
so if we solve the ftp and we find some
kind of a then there's some way that we
can write it like this so sorry the
reason this is not different word not
signed then this would be exactly the
problem is inside so that's already a
good point here so if in fact this was
like a real man you measure and not
assigned measure that this would always
be positive and we would already be done
because of the globalization is already
satisfied so if this was all positive
then in fact this year would be some
kind of probability distribution and we
would have found a solution Sally so we
can only know that it's normalized but
it's not necessarily positive emotion is
kind of how can we turn this I guess I'm
measure into a true measure so we want
to round this so the goal of what I'm
going to discuss is to find the true
probability measure new Q so the optics
is also called do representation such
that an approximation which I will call
as even if basically all of thumb is I
have taken pills and replaced it with Q
as the property that this closely
approximates in peace
just one spot if small in some epsilon
which I'll deter
yes
[ __ ] me anytime so hold the form of
approximation and so i will write it
down explicitly but you can think that
it's defined actually by evaluating this
is what i've done here is i've written
ly merely to indicate that here i'm
going to integrate over wine yes
resolution i had omitted the l because
it was not so important we had only one
variable so l of wine at this current
here so i write k of x to be the current
function where i fixed the X element in
a very over my son integrating over
white so you have f of X and here I take
the expectation i right EFX if i take
the expectation with respect to the
uniform measure
is this one over lambda 0 so one of a
number here which is the first times I
guess eigenvalues of the Colonel's the
kind of sneak in so this here is I can
value long / 0 0 I believe that goes
with a noise space are 0 and maybe
remember that this corresponds to the
space of constant functions there's a
few things that we should check namely
we should check that it's normalized so
why is this a normalized so what I'm to
check this i'm going to plug in here the
constant function okay so here would be
the constant function i permitted it not
because it's just fun
so what I can do now is I guess I think
about this I can commute these two
things I can exchange of all people I
guess recent exchange so now we have
some properties so remember in fact that
the lowest order eigen value can be
obtained
only holston function which speaks in
your lowest eigenvalue of the colonel is
that this here in fact it's just as well
so we're not the zero goes away exists
under zero and then i use the property
that my FCP solution was normalized in
the sense that if i evaluate this at the
constant function so the expectation
this isn't like a normalized expectation
you should be like iterate over all X
we're good or maybe I check clear miss
something HP will give you this one or
this one so that
no matter how I spent later so not that
like here it is you can think about it
just like with the matrix I have assumed
that the eigenfunctions are also moment
and the lowest i can value the lowest
space like the the 0 a 0 is the constant
function which means that this theory we
just gives me noticing but i can show
you
so the second thing that we wanted to
check is easy positive so to ensure that
it's positive let's remember some nice
property that we had for a valid current
namely the ballot colonel was a square
of socially this here was a polynomial
of degree it was L in white and I know
from the SCP constraint that in fact my
vision evaluated at a polynomial of
degree like Q squared where Q is a
polynomial of degree mosey this here is
in fact positive so this value colonel
together with this SCP constraint also
guarantee me that this thing is positive
so let me to make this more explicit and
one other way to write this down is I
could have written down so this measure
that I'm constructing in the following
way so 1 over the lowest i can value of
the colonel so this comes from this here
i have my FCP solution again i just all
right to emphasize integrating the work
here i have my colonel
basically this means that my
approximation is going to look like this
so is now kind of constructed an
approximation but of course not the
obvious question is how good is this
approximation or how can we actually
hope to say anything about the goodness
of the suboxone so in order to do this I
want to come think think that what is
the relation between P and Q and i will
look at this kind of from two different
ways first one is I just wanted to
infect expand it so again again I'm
summing over J so you should be thinking
that I'm doing with decomposition here
again if you think about the sphere just
think about decomposing this in two
monomials of certain degrees of j
against the corresponds to the space
spanned by the spherical harmonics of
the green
I'm going to be interested what can I
say about the relation between you it's
jay and mu P so just let's again think
remember like from the previous slide
how are the new queue defines okay so i
had written it in the following but i'm
going to expand it which makes this may
be a bit more obvious so here i'm
integrating and what appears here is in
fact my current law and the ribbon that
might kind of look like this so here is
rj constant on the space okay and here
is Ivan values lambda J so basically all
this Colonel is going to do is it's
going to tack on a lambda J on all the
components what this means is that queue
at component J is not the jay like this
where i have the lambda 0 here coming
from
are you gonna say what these are for the
spiracles months so I'm going to
actually able to never write them out
explicitly and because so far I have not
tells you that what this crime is I'm
not going to optimize our Colonels and
then we will see how to find
it's all think however that I want to
point out here is that if you think
about what is the relation between P and
Q so the original ACP solution and the
approximation that we are constructing a
related in fact by the eigenvalues of
the colonel in particular do you think
in fact if we had normalized the colonel
such that lambda 0 would in fact be one
if you want to think about it this way
then what this mean is here is that
remember that my fully reproducing
kernel at I ghen values all one and if I
only were able to use fully reproducing
kernel then p would actually be equal to
Q I won't quite achieve this in fact the
reason that prevents us from achieving
this is because they won't have this
valid colonel
see here that what we want to do is we
kind of wanted to make this here as
closest to one as we possibly can so
again let me emphasize this and if you
look at this it's kind of obvious then
it wouldn't be great if like this ratio
was actually equal to one so you can
intuitively think that what we are going
to try and do is we want that this here
so this kernel like normalized is in
fact a good approximation to the fully
reproducing kernel and instead of
thinking about this relation between P&Q
let me actually write it in yet another
way that again emphasizes what we were
really trying to do here so remember
that we are interested in the difference
between my true SDP solution and this
approximation that unconstructive so let
me kind of expand this so here and what
I'm done is I've just kind of plugged in
the definition of this approximation and
I've used the fact that this is
reproducing to also write this here as
an integral but now with respect to the
fully reproducing kernel so what you can
see appearing here is in fact that here
we have the difference between the fully
reproducing kernel and this guy here so
it would be really great if we could
make this close to the fully reproducing
kernel
we cannot okay so what does prevents us
from this so notice that I had imposed
some restrictions of this kernel because
I wanted it to be valid in particular I
wanted to be a square of dysfunction
Zeta XY where theta X Y was a polynomial
in Y of degree at most l so you can
think that what we're really doing here
is we're trying to approximate this data
function to truly reproduce environment
by using ever larger kernels of ever
increasing degree if EDD would go to
infinity they were perfectly
approximately this delta function is for
your isn't around but is there any find
that l we can only try and kind of get
somewhere in the vicinity because
putting long as a flow that we cannot be
to psyche and you want it to be a spiky
as possible
so let me maybe to summarize what we do
agrees so far I have not as arm has
suggested you asking what are the
eigenvalues of this cannon I have not
picked one yet so choose a valid colonel
establish that this P representation
here it's easy to see that this is so
for a hierarchy that you've already
written down not in this form for
example for the quantum people on this
kind of tensor product spaces you would
then have to first argue that the ASIS
kind of P representation you can define
a cube representation using this kernel
so note that a different kernels if of
course different humor presentations and
in the end what we had done it with the
proximity with Q basically we're just
takin RP and spoken q
so now what is the approximation
guarantee they will be getting and I
want to state a to general theorem and i
will say shortly why this is in fact to
general and i want to specialize this in
fact two polynomials and which live in
just over 30
so if K Isabella colonel and I'm going
to form this approximation as we've just
stuff then it's true for all j actually
I would've been less confusing j here in
fact the following quantity is less than
1 minus this approximation ratio so what
did this was in fact what related p and
q are you probably wondering what is
this kind of thing that I was here
so I like to write it here and to remind
us also of these I guess there's some
kind of quantum sync speaking in there
but in terms of notation in terms of
that you can think that this here is a
distance measure between and how is this
defined basically we are maximizing
overall polynomials of degree in jail
some of these guys the absolute value of
the maximum and the maxim of the
absolute value is at most fun and I'm
looking at the difference between the
original SDP solution and so in fact
what we can show us we can show this
general statement okay in fact the codes
for all such people
and what you can already see why I'm
saying this is too general in fact the
construction that i'm going to do i
claim that it's good for all p of a
certain degree not just the s the one
that we actually wanted to optimize but
in fact my approximation will look very
similar to my stp solution for all
polynomials of the people you can see
that they actually overshooting our goal
a little bit they're proving something
which is actually slightly too powerful
for the original task if we wanted to
consider so maybe for the quantum people
this is quite analogous to kind of these
quantum very many theorems and where in
fact you want to do some l1 norm
approximation I would like to emphasize
again only for the common people if you
wrote the translators to the quantum
language you would actually be proving
an approximation in a norm that is even
stronger than the other one
what we do is and this is why I wanted
to wear this calculation for some pj
sorry yes you is it clear why there
should be infinity norm for that you
knocked over p with intervene well yes
so not that actually may be going if you
think about actually the definity and
the l1 norm what you have here in fact
is the Infinity norm of matrices but
here I'm interested in the Infinity norm
of functions so this is actually also
the difference between this norm and the
normal l1 norm so if you in the quantum
language I'm sorry for everyone so in
the quantum language like in DF l1 norm
you want to maximize overall measurement
operators em here you want to only
maximize over measurement operators
which are like extensor l and I'm
interested in like that this year is
bounded for all but of course this is a
I mean I'm allowing kind of more things
I only wanted it's normalized for x 10 x
10 cell instead of having really largest
eigen value less than so it's like eight
separate most one or anything
but it isn't it's a lot that I have I'm
like I said I'm not so successful i have
tries to eliminate all these matrices so
this really is the norm of the function
so this is the maximum of the likely and
the maximum of the absolute value of pj
abnormalities what's a [ __ ] states
are startling so this is one and so this
is the difference that we want to bound
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to do the same calculation as before
we're here I plucked in the definition
ok and here I've just written it in
terms of this reproducing kernel so know
that I can always do that because it's
flat so now how do i get from here to
that note that this he only lived on the
jay z component so here I'm summing of
oj here i am also summing over all j
heroes if the island is but because this
he only lives on the Jays components i
can ignore all the other ones i only get
rj appear here so i can here's an rj
here's an object ok
for this year outside and note that this
here is again reproducing on the space
DJ between look back my SP solution and
and let's remember that in fact is he
was mobilized in fact for all of these
guys I guess the shooting a business m1
so now i have just an approximation
omitted the absolute value in the
previous line because it's going to be
positive a white horse wants to measure
LLY corresponds to a measure soon note
that a is my sdp solution it is my i
guess in your language pseudo
expectation there is a 14 yes i'm just
writing why here to integrate to specify
always you can see i'm integrating twice
like it once integrating over X and
integrating over y which is why I just
put a wire just remind ourselves that
here I'm integrating
like you're saying like K of X Y is a
functionable x and y so you apply the
pseudo expectation operator you could
have applied at either the X or the y
coordinate about less inequality because
we like the fact that the people I is
unfounded by one it doesn't necessarily
mean to deceive expectation if you have
a function that's as its maximum value
is one does it mean that it's that's it
for every suitor expectation is at most
one I guess that would mean only if it's
a measure the rate enjoy maybe seen
maybe see the polynomial of degree at
most j and why is a civil expectation of
level larger than Jamie keys to fight
because moving like a hockey watch into
the next next step away I'm actually
wondering whether I cut some call my
hair because I
actually I'm sure on that I don't have
to think about it so note that this is
actually not quite the argument that I'm
making but I thought I could compress it
so once upon a time some local time ago
and we wanted to optimize some
polynomial okay and and I want to now
make an assumption about this polynomial
namely that it's true minimum and it's
true maximum are on the opposite sides
of the zero ok so the tribunal resistant
Sir Andrew maximum is rated so you might
object to this but note that i can
easily transform my situation into one
where this is the case actually evaluate
my polynomial at some arbitrary point x0
and i'm going to consider this
polynomial piece bar which is like is my
original line is the value at this
particular so this satisfies this
condition and in particular also if i
take the difference between the maximum
and minimum then in fact i get back the
difference between the original use this
year is just
so how close is the SDP solution to the
true optimum so note that because these
guys on opposite sides we also know that
this here is less than the difference
between the maximum and the moon so we
have by this I guess zebra that the
difference between the true SCP solution
and their approximation adventures
constructing is less than epsilon so
epsilon here was 1 minus this eigen
value ratio times this year so in my
when I stated it I had assumed that this
here is less than one of course may be
in general its loss less than 1 and in
this case of course you can transform it
into this bound and now you can apply
this situation here to show that this is
less than epsilon times this difference
so in general like if this is the true
minimum then
sdp solution will be less than that
because I allow more matrices that are
minimizing over my approximation which
is comes from a true probability measure
will least the minimum
so we're now using the difference
besides here and like I said to the fact
that we've just constructed it and one
can transform it into a statement like
this namely that SP solution approximate
cetera minimum from below it was people
buy some fancy house this difference
apparently this is how you guys like to
write out of this approximately
so like I really said before like what
we've done here is we fuse the
polynomial kernel here we kind of use
general curls indeed so and we have not
yet set for these crimes actually are
and so this is kind of in this our
original result was kind of inspired by
quantum information we argued that we
prove some kind of definite e theorem it
would maybe like to emphasize for the
quantum information people here that one
could also kind of approve calton
definity theorems from the colonel
perspective they're usually kind of you
interested in approximating by certain
class of states for example some
coherent states and this will infect all
have any more choice do I can then just
need to compute the oil and I would like
to say that in fact if you don't work in
this abstract setting but this is right
on some if some other end SCP relaxation
and then in fact ap representation
always exists if there's unique mapping
from polynomial to polynomial a disease
and in this case I guess you have to
find the eigenvalues of the colonel to
obtain
so you have kind of proceeded much more
abstractly and you of course I wondering
how am I going to choose the right
colonel so remember that we were trying
to do is we're trying to kind of make
the eigenvalues actually of our kernel
as close to one as possible because that
would give us the fully reproducing
kernel but we don't have so much to play
with because our kernel is a square or
something that's like at most degree l
in one so we're not going to optimize
over kernels and I will restrict myself
to Colonel switch her so-called zonal so
Colonel a bit sony has the following
property namely that's invariant under
the automorphism group of the object ok
so for the sphere this is like a
phenomenal group so this means that if i
rotate x and if i rotate why then my
kernel function is invariant
he's my son again this polynomial kernel
is obviously has this property if this
inner product is invariant
the zonal functions can be simplified
example you can read all about it in
functional survey that m1 can write them
out in terms of supporting both
polynomials so here again are the
eigenvalues but instead of writing like
ours here and writing something about
Game Boy polynomial when is stupid
insect depends only on the inner product
between X and
so forth in our these are the game ball
polynomials for example the bouillon
cube pieces the Crouch of polynomials
and it's all kinds of other orthogonal
polynomials will be polynomial for
complex projective spaces and so on so
what does he look like again just maybe
two for the CSO in the sphere you could
also write this out in terms of strategy
harmonics just to emphasize really what
these oranges of course I'm not just
going to think about it in terms of this
key
but what one could use some kind of
established colonel in fact apparently i
learned from powder this is something
called the vehicle of concurrent and
which in fact turns out she in fact also
to be the optimal but we can also find
it and for optimal zonal crown so how do
we do this so let me consider this here
so actually to confuse you in my hand
written on site for this Zeta now i'm
going to call it little cane because i
wasn't quite sure how to so this is a
function i'm going to square and so I
mean this is just some in function that
I'm going to assume is invariant okay
but can decompose it into getting power
polynomials and some coefficients which
I will call a charge a so these are not
the eigenvalues of the final colonel
because we're going to square this thing
how can we find the eigenvalues of this
kind of squared colonel given
okay they even know that he can write it
out in terms of Eatonville polynomials
in the scheme of all polynomials or
token inverse respect this n is the
dimensional yeah they kind of orthogonal
and I think recover it is eigen value
lambda by sorting the following
again unfortunately so that's maybe just
a little okay
so know that my kernel should look like
this okay so this year so i'm not going
to compute this eigen values and so I've
kind of showed you already what happens
for getting all polynomials in general
note that I could also think about it
this way
so note that I can always find the
eigenvalues if I find a function in this
some kind of safe which I know the value
so if I know this function that's an
especial point then i can just complete
the form that's maybe this just as a
note decide if you want
can we go do this this I'm not going
I've decided not to actually do this
calculation in this hawk just because so
we get this is some kind of doesn't
actually it's not funny concept of
course depends on the damages yeah but
let's not worry about it here this is
not essential to the understanding so of
course you can write it out in terms of
some meetings looks like this this year
atha atha the vector and that appeared
in the functional this year
I really owe them some from terms of
coefficients it hung up and this here is
a matrix of linearization coefficients
okay so what are the mirror is a shin
coefficients again you're a core
technology so these are the game ball
around they tell you if i take the
product of two game ball polynomials how
can I again write it as a sum of
kickball polygamous so there's some kind
of coefficients here which are both the
linearization coefficients
and this matrix will have row and column
entries which are exactly given by this
linearization and I want to start with
like a very simple example where I want
to infect set s to be equal
what so anyway so the first case s
equals one is obviously you will all
know about it in any book on the [ __ ]
in polynomial in this case this can just
be found by recurrence relations and
this matrix and there's some kind of
standard answers for this which leads us
to infect equal to this game power
polynomials as a special evaluated at a
special point which is the root of the
game ball polynomial of people
anyway it gets a bit more interesting in
the general case okay let me just say
what we do there in the general case we
use the same approximation for the
eigenvalue eigenvector so make the same
on sets i'm going to write on the vector
that is again game ball polynomial
evaluated at some special point i would
also take this to be a root in our
polynomial in the vicinity of n + 1 + 4
x equals to one can actually also make
such a nonsense along these lines exact
and for the general case actually this
is I guess where things become a little
bit more interesting it's one has to
show because this would only be an
approximate I convector one has to show
that this these such terms like it's not
quite a guy in vector the ribosome error
terms at the end the dis error term
actually vanish and needs that we're
going to consider is we're going to fix
all over N and we're going to take the
limit of n going to feel
remember n was the dimension of this
here l was the level of the hierarchy so
maybe for the quantum people here again
in quantum usually you like to think
about fixing in like the dimension of
the local system and then we will save a
little of l going to infinity here i'm
going to take a different limit when we
were going to fix it
I would like to emphasize if you were
interested in taking the other limits
it's actually much easier to show that
this error term they banish then for
this particular limit but so what
happened for this year let me show you
plot I'm almost done plus and so the
asymptotic route so I'm interested in
this particular route service this will
give us a mess employee behavior I would
like to say again this is kind of exact
for s equals 1 and x equals 2 and but in
general we study this limit and I'm
going to just show you some plots ok so
these are some plots for increasing
values of n here is theta so this is the
ratio and here is this epsilon so
epsilon is like 1 minus lambda M s over
lambda 0
so this is kind of striped this the
dotted line is the asymptotic bulbs and
you can see that is n increases we get
closer
so one can also do this for the cube and
the idea is in fact exactly the same and
of course because these are looking
about polynomials they Crouch of
polynomials business they have different
linearization coefficients which means
that this matrix will look different we
will have different eigenvalues
therefore giving us rebound here also
some America Bonds and there's maybe
just one thing that I want to point out
for the Q maybe for the cube that some
virgins like which is kind of we
approach this as a 30-pound it's
actually much lower than for the sphere
it will still already grows stronger so
note that also the ended I've chosen
thing is much larger so here n goes from
20 to 1000 here had just picked n going
from 20
so happy to say like why does this give
us a better approximation so previously
like for the sphere um in this handsome
city would have had something like n
over n if n squared over in spin for me
well keyboard it was in LA and spilled
over wasn't it you got something so all
right it's exactly the same bias or
accomplished yes not also that what you
do is the case like one can actually
understand what they are doing and in
this current picture if you wanted to do
that because you could define the
colonel from them and work evaluate if
the case is equals 1 so this is the case
will in fact be matrix
awesome so okay anyway for this I'm what
I wanted to say my wife discussing this
case of the sea on the cube and but note
that there's some general recipe
basically you identify the relevant also
going to polynomials you find the
linearization coefficients all of this
of course that's easy you right to the
colonel eigen values in terms of these
linearization coefficients you solve
this eigenvalue problem first you don't
necessarily have to do this you can also
just guess it colonel and then you step
one you can compute its eigenvalues
you're in business but if you wanted to
end all the lives of our Colonels then
you could forward
or if we done with this kind of general
methods to prove convergence found such
person CNN you open all kinds of other
spaces and I'd like to emphasize that
what we've been doing before dendron I
did before it's a special case what
we're doing here and if we can kind of
cover this approximate representing
measure and in fact we also get
something better for the hypersphere
then
so I've not talked about this here dish
see my guess because I was apologizing
watch this stuff so it is a sum of
squares picture what so I'm gonna talk
about this here before and this circle
so there's maybe a bit too many open
questions and I guess let me just
highlight the ones which I think are
most interesting so the first one is
like i said already in this kind of
general theorem we have overshot our
goal okay because we have constructed an
approximation that was kind of close to
the SDP solution evaluated any
polynomial of the degree of course we
don't want to evaluate or for any
polynomial of the degree because you
only want to optimize one specific one
and in fact I guess generally we will
know which or probably knowing you want
to optimize in advance right Amelia so
to the SDP for them so so erratic
polynomials this and did something more
sophisticated the phone can do but of
course quadratic polynomials on the
sphere
and there's also another very
interesting question and which more to
the kind of quantum crowd and so like I
said so we can reprove this kind of real
value definitely theorem we could also
reprove this kind of existing definitive
here with one and a half divinity serum
on complex projective space and but it
might be very interesting to consider
some affinity series of other spaces or
other physical objects for example and
some fermion systems and the question
does can be used similar techniques and
they're typically we will not be
optimizing over the Colonel's but the
seller will be dictated by the set of
states that we want to approximate width
and then of course the challenges can we
compute the eigenvalues of this kernel
and if you can then